-Ewan, it is --
ah, look at you, buddy.
You look great.
-How are you?
-It's good to see you.
-I am happy to see you.
-Where were you when
everything shut down?
Were you working on anything
at the time?
-I was in New York.
I was working on the series
called "Halston."
And I'd been in New York.
We'd shot about one episode
out of five, and bits
of two or three.
So we were less than
halfway through it.
-Oh.
-And then, you know,
we were shooting and we were
hearing all this talk
on set about other
films being shut down.
And we're thinking, "Why are we
not being shut down?
What -- what --"
And then of course,
it came one Friday.
They shut us down --
literally.
But we thought, at that stage,
it was going to be
for two or three weeks.
-I totally agree.
Yeah.
-You know, it's like
two, three weeks, go home.
So I just left a bunch
of my stuff in New York
and I flew back here to L.A.,
and here we are
six months later.
It's unbelievable, isn't it?
-What kind of things you been
doing while you've been home?
-Well, you know, I've
just been keeping busy, dude.
I did a whole bunch of stuff
that I've been meaning to do
around the place, like things
that you go, "I'll get to that,"
picking up a tree that fell over
or I lost a trailer
down the hill.
I had to get --
I towed that out.
Things that have been on
my to-do list for years.
You know, played
a lot of guitar.
I actually -- I found you
playing "Render" with Blur
on the interwebs.
-You saw that?
-Oh, my God.
I watched it over and over.
It's so good.
-How great are --
I just asked them to do it.
They were here and I go,
"I love 'Tender' so much.
Do you want to --"
How did you stumble on that one?
-I don't know.
I was just trying to learn
the chords for it.
And I was looking on YouTube
to see -- you know,
I was watching them play it,
and then I saw you guys.
I was thinking, "Wait a minute."
So looked at it,
and then I kept watching
you over and over.
Just -- what I loved about it
is you just looked like you were
having so much fun.
It was the best.
-It was great --
-Your were playing with Blur.
-If you look at
Damon's face,
he starts laughing because
he's looking at
how much fun I am having.
And I'm hitting harmonies
and stuff, he's like --
-You're doing the high stuff.
You were so into it.
-I'm trying and he's
laughing at me.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, that's great, man.
-It's so cool.
-We got to do --
-We got to do a duet
when you come back.
-Oh, I'd love that.
I'd love to --
Any excuse, really,
to get the guitar out.
You know, I'd love it.
-Yeah.
-Last time you were here,
you'd just finished
a motorcycle trip
with your buddy, Charley.
-Charley. Yeah. Yeah.
-Now it's a series
on Apple TV+.
"Long Way Up,"
it debuts Friday.
What can we expect for this?
-We did a couple of other
big trips in the past
called "Long Way Round"
and "Long Way Down."
And we -- in 2004,
we rode from London
all the way around
to New York, east.
-I remember, yeah.
-And that was epic.
And then we did
the African continent
from the top of Scotland
to Cape-Town in 2007.
And, you know, there's been
this long gap in between,
but we always planned
to do the Americas.
And so we started, we --
we did an odd --
we prepped it al
in L.A. and London
and then shipped everything
down to Ushuaia
in the bottom of
Tierra del Fuego to start,
which was such a --
We had to come a long way up,
you know,
'cause we'd already done
"Long Way Down."
The common sense thing would be
to leave L.A. and ride south,
but 'cause we had to call it
"Long Way Up,"
we had to start down there.
-Down, and go up.
-Then we shipped
everything down there
and we rolled all the way back
up to L.A., and it was amazing.
And we did it all
on electric motorcycles.
We decided to try and do
this one on electric bikes.
And Harley-Davidson took
their beautiful
LiveWire motorcycle
and built
these two prototypes into
sort of adventure bikes for us.
They raised the suspension,
or they lengthened
the suspension,
they raised the bikes.
Put different seats on
and panniers
and a screen and we had these
proper dual sports bikes.
It was wicked.
-You said that this was
the most challenging
motorcycle trip
that you've ever done.
What was one of the more
challenging part of it?
-I think the challenge was
the charging of the bikes.
You know, we're in the cusp of,
I know, electric cars
are everywhere.
There are electric charging
stations for cars
in most cities.
Especially in America,
it's quite easy to do,
to navigate.
But in the Atacama Desert
or Patagonia, for instance,
there aren't any
charging stations...
-Of course.
-...so we had to sort of
do the best we could.
It was pretty stressful,
the charging.
But it added a certain
excitement to the trip,
a different kind of
adventure, you know.
It was good.
-How do you like
electric versus gas powered?
-I love it. I love --
I love riding them.
They're really fast.
I mean, they're --
Away from the lights,
they are so much faster
than a petrol bike, and...
-Really?
-They're just --
they're sort of --
For a touring bike,
they're quite nice
'cause they don't make
any noise,
and there's no
mechanical vibrations,
so you really feel the road.
There's sort of a --
sort of tranquility
to riding them,
which is nice.
You ride them a bit slower
because
you got to try and get
the most miles
out of the battery
as you can.
-Yeah.
-And so you don't want to be
setting at 90 miles an hour,
but that lends itself
for touring anyway.
You want to be able
to take in the landscape
and look at the llamas
as you go by, you know?
And also, the llamas
don't run away.
So when you come up
on a petrol bike
to horses or some wildlife,
they scatter.
But when you come up
on an electric bike
to the llamas, they just
sort of check you out.
They don't run off.
-I wouldn't even think of that.
You're right.
I remember I was lucky enough
to go on a hot-air balloon
ride...
-Yeah.
-...in Africa,
and when we went over the
animals, you're just floating,
and it's quiet,
so the animals
don't even really
know you're there.
They just think you're a bird,
so you're just like,
"Oh, my goodness,
this is unbelievable."
-Amazing.
-So that's probably
kind of the same thing --
it's not as loud,
so once they do --
[ Imitates grinding ]
...then they ran
and they go...
-Yeah.
-Then you're like, alright.
Then it wasn't as peaceful.
Hot-air ballooning's not as
peaceful as everyone says it is.
-The landings aren't quite
as peaceful as --
The landings are
pretty terrifying.
-Dude, it was awful.
-Sort of like --
It's so hit-and-miss,
isn't it?
It's sort of like, well,
I hope it's gonna be okay.
-Yeah, we're all tumbling
out of a basket.
I go, "This is not
how I want to go."
-Dragged across the Savanna
being chased by leopards.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-That must have unbelievable
just listening to the tire
on the road, and just going,
"We're going, man,
we're cruising."
-Yeah, I mean,
we got down there,
and we're not very good --
we're not very clever
at planning, Charley and I.
We like looking at bikes
and picture--
You know, we love
buying the kit,
getting the right panniers
and the right gloves
and the right gloves and --
-Yeah.
-That's what we're really into,
all the kit,
you know, the stuff.
But the actual planning
of the trip,
we're a bit lame at,
so we go down there
to Tierra del Fuego,
and it was a blizzard,
and we were snowed in
for four days
before we could leave,
'cause it was still winter.
And I spoke to my dad
on the phone, he was like,
"Well, you might have looked
at the weather
before you left, son,"
you know.
I'm thinking, yeah,
he's got a point.
I should have had a look
at the weather
because it was
blizzard conditions.
-You're like, "I'm too busy
thinking of the bike
and the gloves and thing
and the --" yeah.
-"I got really nice panniers,
Dad, look at my panniers."
But...
[ Laughter ]
But we waited for a break
in the weather,
and on the fifth day
it stopped snowing a bit,
and we just left,
we just got out on the road.
It was fun.
-I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here is a look
at "Long Way Up"
on Apple TV+,
check it out.
-Got to hold on
through your pillar.
I once was in a taxi cab
in New York,
and a Hell's Angel came up
to the car like this,
put his hand through
the window and he said,
"Take me to the
Hell's Angels club."
Taxi guy was like, "Okay."
Put your rear window down
and I'll hold on through there.
Go slowly.
Okay, slowly.
-Hold the other way,
maybe, Ewan.
-No, I'm good, I got it.
-You got it?
-Yeah.
Slowly, slowly.
That's it, good.
-Okay.
-Good.
-...faster?
-Yeah, go a bit faster.
Ooh, yeah, that's good.
Good, good, good.
This is working,
it's working.